a lot of people ask me because you know
after the demise of twisted demise of my
musical career yeah I went and did so
many things and and was successful and
and you know and brought myself back
yeah you've done something you've done
everything from writing to hosting to
radio to have a real time everything if
you want reality to Broadway I've been
on Broadway
you know people ask me what like what
drove you I said 10% inspiration 90%
desperation Wow and that desperation
that fear of that fall of happening
again still drives me you know if you
told my wife you know there I said I
said yeah so you know we're entered you
know in retirement mode she's like what
and I said you know well I'm sort of
like easing up she goes come here she
just hands me a legal pad one of those
big long yellow ones it's like a foot
long she goes right down the things
you're working with I build an entire
page where things I'm working on in
different stages she goes yeah we're
retiring here oh well I mean you know so
but but I've had this terror inside of
me because it was such a brutal fall it
was so humbling and it was so ugly and
it was so humiliating and devastating to
the ego to the ego you know that I just
I just started anything if people would
say do you want I go yes
and I go I didn't say what yeah y'all do
it whatever it is I mean literally so
when someone said hey you got a good
voice you - voiceover okay what do I do
yeah you know you know um you should be
a radio uh you can you know you get this
you're that I just I managed like I said
anything if I showed any inclination to
be possibly do it I just started trying
to do it you know did you feel like a
sellout or do you feel like a survivor
this is the weird thing so I'm still
trying to keep up still got fingers in
rock and roll first
it's you know was Widowmaker and already
the bottoms falling out so I'm trying to
pull out of it with a new band
so I'm putting on the facade when I go
out of being still be a rock star not
letting people in and let them know the
truth never invite them back to the
house yeah never you know so and
why wouldn't I believe that D still have
made millions why how who would assume
he blew it Millions last forever as far
as people are killing you we blew
everything so I'm putting on the facade
and not letting people know so when I'm
walking on the streets I've got you know
baseball hat on and you know hair's
pulled back at that point that people
aren't used to that pulled back hair you
know and if people say hey aren't you go
no no no no I'm not uh and you know my
kids know every called me Fred you know
my wife calls me Fred the store easily
hey Brett and he says she knows not to
call me D and it's so I'm hiding my
shame you know so no I'm I'm definitely
it was brutal man it was brutal
yeah I mean you really seem like a
survivor it's so hot I don't think
people realize how hard it is to stay
relevant and working in this business
for a lifetime it's a thank you and I
think you're paying me a comment and I
am it's a hostile and it's but it's not
by design right people I saw an article
in a business magazine that's cited Dee
Snider as branding himself he used me as
an example and I was like well that's
beautiful the way they wrote out I did
and they they sort of broke it down and
analyzed you know like how I'd put sort
of how thought out this was none of that
was my design I was no I'm just I'm just
you know I actually would slam my name
on everything now tell people to put
your name on everything but even that
started happening by accident right you
know we're wound up on being on a movie
I did decider strange land and then also
it was okay well house a hair designers
house a hair and so it's slammed Dee
Snider Dee Snider Dee Snider but it was
never some thought out like it's so
branding right when I write when I write
when you and I started communicating I
said man I don't know if there's anybody
who's branded himself as the first thing
popped into my head as well as Dee
center now literally has a registered my
name is it's copy written and is it's a
trade dee Snider brand that you know but
it was net it was not some brilliant eye
I would love to say yes I knew it all
along said
ah it's just like white noise of
screaming in the darkness and just ah
and made it work
so it's not as much masterminding as
much as it is just mining every moment
kind of yeah and just brute dumb force
just forcing it
you know just in it's a square peg just
[ __ ] it
I can get it in the round hole somehow
I'll wear the edges you know whatever it
really is there's no genius to it at all
honestly do I have talents I clearly had
Sunday I believe and I developed them
you guys like radio you know um uh you
know I always liked radio I and my book
was called shut up is called shut up and
give me the mic I love radio I love the
forum but yes my agent said look you
don't walk off of a concert stage into a
six-figure radio cake it happened once
David Lee Roth replacing Howard Stern
anybody ever to hear that remember that
did you see that oh my god it was
catastrophic because it is because you
would sing doesn't mean you can be an
air personality yeah they're two
different skills so I had to go and do
the metal show a couple hours a week and
slowly develop that displaces yeah
writing you know I wrote the twist
sister videos but is this me going all
right well the father's yelling at the
kid and then the kid throws it to D
Snider and he kicks his ass that was me
writing the video yeah we've already
called her credit Sam already called the
director for developing and recognizing
that it had some kind of brilliance but
then I said well I want to write these
things and I had to study screenplay
writing and I've sold a number of shows
and a number of you know I've got a
number of things now and and movies and
things like that I've developed had
things produced but that was a craft you
have to develop you know it just doesn't
come to you thank you guys for checking
out this clip and if you want to see
another clip and you can look at this
clip or this clip either one of these so
did you pick one or he's still just
watching me do this because it's
alarming